she describes them in religious terms
but not
not the good religion not in the bright
light heavenly terms
she describes it in hellish terms this
could not be more diabolical
and i think that democrats need to be
absolutely clear at the federal level in
this fight with mcconnell and trump but
also
in the senate races that any vote for
any republican
is literally a vote to cost you money to
make your health care
more expensive and maybe to eliminate
the possibility you'll be able to afford
it
at all anyone else notice how happy
hillary clinton looked when she said the
word diabolical
she goes yes it's uh it's really
it's diabolical
she's sort of stirring whatever is in
her cauldron
uh yeah hillary clinton certainly
certainly gets a thrill by that word
diabolical but diabolical is a good word
to use not for what the republicans are
doing but for what the democrats are
doing you don't need to take my word for
it take the word of the huffington post
woman writing for the huffington post
jamie smith writes
the death of justice ruth bader ginsburg
pushed me to join the satanic temple
there's a picture of like baphomet or
something some kind of satanic symbol
i'm a 40-something attorney and mother
who lives in a quiet neighborhood with a
yard and a garage full of scooters and
soccer balls
i'm not the type of person who would
normally consider becoming a satanist
but these are not normal times are they
not
are they not normal i actually think
these are normal times we always say
we're living in such crazy times i mean
they're interesting times
but the times are interesting generally
life is the world is very interesting
and i i have to disagree with this woman
i think that she's exactly the type of
person
who would become a satanist the type of
person
who thinks she doesn't really
have strong religious views she actually
says here that the satanic temple
they're atheists
it's not like they're they're believing
in some spiritual thing they're actually
atheists they don't think god exists
they don't think the spiritual world
exists okay
but they just think these damn
republicans are so crazy
they're they're they're theocrats
they're
they're awful and we should all be
afraid she says i fear that american
citizens are inching closer to living in
a theocracy or a dictatorship
and that the check's meant to prevent
this from happening are close to eroding
fundamental despair
and the satanic temple they just believe
in fundamental tenets
such as uh the struggle for justice is
an ongoing and necessary pursuit
that should prevail over laws and
institutions and that one's body is
inviolable subject to one's will
alone and you know these are things that
we believe plenty of people believe in
them
this is exactly how satanism operates
you think a satanist is just like scary
people in robes doing all sorts of
things
no no the greatest trick the devil ever
played
was convincing people that he does not
exist
that's always how the devil has operated
the greatest trick
that the devil has up his sleeve the
greatest temptation is to distract you
with the things of this world
don't need to take my word for it that's
the gospel truth
to distract you to tempt you with things
such as power
which is what this woman is talking
about or filling your physical desires
or indulging your appetites christ's
temptation by the devil in the
wilderness
is that right
that's that is how it operates and when
we use these terms
diabolical these are they really are
getting at something
don't you think it's a little weird that
all of these people who are
who come from i guess different
backgrounds different geographical
backgrounds different political
backgrounds
all the political issues on the table
the one that is holding them up
the one that is going to create this
chaos for the supreme court nomination
is whether or not we have the right to
kill a million babies
this should not this is not a
complicated issue the issue of abortion
is not complicated we pretend it's
complicated there's a new movie out
on hbo max called unpregnant i'll do a
review of it coming up
but it's about it's like a buddy trip
about going out and killing a bunch of
babies
this is not a complicated issue do you
think a country should allow
its citizens to kill a million babies a
year
no nobody thinks so then there are all
these tricks they say well it's not
really a baby it's not really human
not really alive yeah it's all of those
things it's very clearly all of them i
have a sonogram i can show you
i can show you that it's all of those
things forget about even the
philosophical arguments which are all
very clear
don't you think that's a weird
coincidence actually that's like an odd
thing
shouldn't we be arguing about taxes or
foreign policy or or actual health care
or that no
because these diabolical
influences these diabolical people these
people actually joining the satanic
temple
they know not what they do i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]